le stade jean maréchal de montigny le
bretonneux et en plein lifting la ville
a déboursé près de six cent quarante
deux mille euros pour rénover les
terrains de la structure pendant
l'intersaison le synthétique daté du
début des années 2000 on va voir quand
même un moquette synthétique de qualité
conformes lusage baseball
chose qui n'était pas forcément évident
sur l'ancienne moquette
bon après on a aussi les normes qui
évolue régulièrement donc là on sera
vraiment un jour des dernières normes
commence à être usé les joueurs
partaient avec une grande partie du
terrain dans leurs chaussettes tous les
soirs après les matches après les
entraînements
et puis surtout il était devenu très dur
et ça commençait à leur donner mal au
genou après avoir débuté en juillet les
travaux qui devaient s'achever en août
ont pris du retard
la livraison définitive est finalement
programmée d'ici fin septembre
des délais qui ont poussé le club des
cougars de montigny le bretonneux à
jouer leur quart de finale des play-off
de d1 contre paris à l'extérieur il vaut
mieux attendre et puis avoir quelque
chose qui correspondent tout à fait à
nos attentes et je pense que vu ce que
l'on nous a dit que nous allions avoir
ça va correspondre forcément une fois
terminée la structure accueillera entre
180 et 200 joueurs par semaine et des
groupes scolaires